[موسيقى]
عندما كان الرئيس الله يرحمه بالحكم كانت
يعني تتداول بالاوساط العراقيه موضوع وجود
اكثر من شبيه
فبيوم اللي التقينا انا وياه من دخلوا
الامريكان وانا كنت جالس اتبادر الى ذهني
بعد ان شفت وضعها يعني شكله نتيجه ظروف
المعتقل والظروف الاعتقال وما حصل الى
يعني من تعذيب نفسي وجسدي في المعتقل
تبادر الى ذهني انه الرئيس قد يكون الشبيه
في هذه اللحظه لكن اتعاملت اني وكانه
الرئيس يعني الامور كيف انه هو تيقنت بعد
ان بدا
احداث يعني باللقاء الاول بده يسرد
الاحداث انا اعرفها سابقا لا يمكن ان يكون
شبيه بعدين شبيه ما يمكن ان يكون مطابق
ولا حتى الدرجه 40%
كان في بعض الكلمات السر اذا صح التعبير
فيما بعد بينه وبين بعض معارفه في الخارج
اكدت لك ايضا فيما بعد بانه هو صدام حسين
فيما بعد يعني كلمات في السر وحتى القصائد
اللي نقلتها الاناس معينين يهموه
اكدت الي بما لا يقبل شك انه لا يمكن ان
فيما بعد عرفت انه برنامج شبيه النصح احد
يعني المسؤولين بالدوله والمقرب من عندها
انه راح سياده الرئيس انه راح
يعني ندعي انه لك اشباح مجموعه اشباح
حمايه يعني جانب امني
يعني كانت دعايه فقط لم يكن له اي سبيل
وهو ماذا قال لك كيف اجابك عندما سالته
مباشره عن هذا الموضوع في المعتقل يعني
كان يعني يستهزئ بهذا الموضوع ما يعني ما
الى وجود
[موسيقى]